there's new research with alarming
results is changing the way doctors
treat cervical cancer laparoscopic
surgery is a less invasive procedure
that involves a small incision in the
abdomen it led to a higher risk of death
from cervical cancer and that's compared
with patients who had a traditional
hysterectomy now this is according to
two studies published in the New England
Journal of Medicine
after the less invasive surgery the
cancer was four times think about that
four times more likely to return some
hospitals like Johns Hopkins in Maryland
and MD Anderson Cancer Center that's in
Texas have now switched back to the
traditional surgery or dr. David agus is
an oncologist and leads the USC Westside
cancer center he joins us from Los
Angeles bright and early to discuss oh
it's good to see you David agus morning
Gail so let's start with this normally
if you hear less invasive if I was a
patient I think that's a great thing why
is that not the case in this particular
lesson sure yeah less invasive means
shorter hospitalization less infection
and over the last decade was a dramatic
move so most surgeries have done less
invasive but in this case obviously from
this study we learned and it was
surprising is that dramatically higher
recurrence rate and death rate and we
think it's probably because somehow how
you manipulate the tissue when you do
this or the fact that you have to blow
up the abdomen with air while you do the
surgery so you can see things one of
those actually causes the cancer to
behave differently and we're seeing here
a negative effect on patients and it's
pretty scary so what's causing the
cancer to reoccur here we just don't
know and I think that's part of the
problem is that we don't know where else
we would stop doing that but clearly you
know the FDA regulates technology but
not how we use it and so we as a medical
community need to take a step back and
say hey listen we got to do studies to
show it's safe and the outcome is right
before we use technologies and patients
across the country I know you call this
a wake-up call do you think it extends
beyond cervical cancer
I certainly do I think all technologies
there's the move now to do things
quicker with technology and we have to
step back and say does it make sense for
the cancer obviously if you're a patient
you want the best cancer outcome you
want to be alive to play with your
grandchildren
you don't care about an extra day or two
in the hospital and so the key is that
metric yeah so David stepping back is
makes sense except that surgery still
have to take place so what what does one
do now if one is a doctor and has
trained on these less invasive
techniques well I think we have to go
back to the open procedure and so
doctors were trained on both and they
need to go back to the way it's been
done really until the last decade where
this transition happened but what about
the patient I mean that patient over the
last year to have the laparoscopic
surgery they need to go back and talk to
their doctor and say hey listen maybe my
surveillance you have to look but that
recurrence in me a little bit
differently because I probably have a
higher rate of recurrence than you
originally thought but doctor we know
that you are a proponent of
technological innovation what does this
say about how that relates to science
you're right I mean I love technology
and I think technology is going to be
very important to make all of us live
longer and better but at the same time
we have to vet technology we need a
process in place so we can actually use
it correctly we have to do the studies
because they're not required now we can
use technology however we want when it's
on the market but again I think you as a
patient me as a patient have to go to
the doctor and say is there data that
this actually is better than the
standard procedure before we use a
technology all right David thank you